welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of John
Wick chapter four all the Easter eggs
references callbacks details you missed
oh dang it I probably should have led
with I am Eric Claus this movie was nuts
I had a blast I hope this isn't the end
it's not the end hey And subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive where I
did a comprehensive full movie analysis
of the first John Wick and why it's so
great and he can support our growing
Network by grabbing one of our John Wick
inspired shirts at nerd riot.shop the
film opens with John's fist hitting a
bloody Target as we hear I am the way
into the city of whoa I am the way into
Eternal pain I am the way to go among
the Lost before me there were no created
things but those who last forever as do
I abandon all hope you who are about to
enter here this is a quote from Dante's
Inferno in which Virgil guides Dante
through the nine circles of hell this is
coming of course from Lawrence Fishburne
as the borrower King now sponsoring John
Wick as they go against the high table
since Fishburn joined this franchise in
chapter two all of these movies have
really just been Matrix trilogy reunions
both cast and stunt crew it's just great
to see Fishburn and Reeves together
Morpheus was in many ways Neo's Virgil
and now the Bowery King plays that role
for Jon this whole film more than the
other three that preceded it really is a
journey through hell for Jon and it ends
with him having an opportunity to enter
through the Gates of Heaven but instead
he sits at the steps next the sun rises
over Morocco and four Riders on
Horseback like the Four Horsemen of the
Apocalypse the final writer represents
death in The Book of Revelation as John
does here John fires exactly 15 shots
dropping that third Rider on the 15th
and then promptly reloads Jon always
reloads after firing the precise
magazine capacity in all these movies it
is one of the established rules I
explained in my deep dive analysis while
watching this movie there were some
moments especially during that Arc to
Triumph sequence where he couldn't
always see him reloading but I bet when
we re-watch this on 4K we'll see all
that reloading now in Morocco this
desert rock is actually the same filming
location from a key scene in Lawrence of
Arabia the Elder from John Wick 3 died
apparently it's not been replaced by a
new helter played by George Giorgio the
Elder says the only way John Wick will
ever have peace of Freedom now or ever
is in death and John says I know John
White foreshadowing his death at the end
of this movie and the altar says I'm
afraid you've come a very long way for
nothing and John says yeah not really
bang so Keanu Reeves reportedly only
says 300
reloading not the words this ain't a
book report folks a film is a visual
medium and it's always better to show
not to tell but it is kind of funny 380
words and by my count he kills 180
people just goes to show you the
priorities of these movies and I don't
have a problem with it he said I haven't
spoken in like 15 weeks
he's after like like an Eastwood kind of
vibe you know Clancy Brown as the
harbinger checks into the Continental
with Karen Lance Reddick who recently
passed away just a week before this
movie released R.I.P to one of the best
actors who left us far too early his
death Just Hits differently in this
movie and a reminder that Caron is the
name of the Greek mythological ferryman
across the river sticks in the
Underworld now the harbinger is missing
his ring finger remember in chapter
three Parabellum John had his ring
finger severed and he lost his wedding
band as a price for recommitting himself
to the high table but he never got his
ring back in this movie except I guess
in his death The Harbinger true to his
name of being the harbinger of Doom
reports from the Marquee to Winston that
the hotel is condemned they got an hour
to get the F out as there report to the
Marquee Winston says that Ned Kelly's
final words were before he was hanged
such is life referring to the infamous
Australian Outlaw leader of the Kelly
gang was caught and hanged in 1880. the
Marquis Vincent De gramon Bill Skarsgard
asks Winston if he believes in rules and
he does but also Second Chances
Winston's rules in the first film were
very very important but he did allow
John a second life at the game he's now
paying the price for that tolerance they
have to watch as the Continental is
destroyed in the Marquee shoots Karen
which for many reasons feels like an
earth-shattering violation because
without a Karen we have no one to govern
the passage in and out of the Underworld
the Gates of Hell have been ruptured and
all those inside trapped in Paris or
more specifically Louis XIV Sun Palace
and nearby Versailles we need Kane
Donnie Yin a blind assassin and danian
also played the blind chair at imway in
Rogue one but the actor is himself not
blind Mr Nobody the tracker goes to the
Osaka Continental with his emotional
support dog the manager shimazukoji is
played by the great hiroyuki Sonata
Marshall alert screen Legend recently
seen in Mortal Kombat in The Amazing
film bullet train he provides Sanctuary
for his friend John which gets him in
trouble with the high table men
accompanied by Kane and you'll notice
the lobby and the rooftop have all been
lit red and pink especially with those
cherry blossoms but the lights now shift
to Green as if to say from stop to go
the battle begins this whole Osaka fight
is definitely one of the best fights in
the film Jon and Akira team up to fight
the high table soldiers now these guys
are heavily armored up like Samurai one
blocks every one of John's shots with
this body armor until John has just had
enough he grabs his leg tilts back the
Torso exposing the guy's neck and then
John shoots up through the neck I love
how these soldiers have these
interesting masks with faces that seem
to be rooted in Japanese mythology after
parting with Akira and shimazu John goes
alone in the gallery this is when things
get real cool there's one move in
particular where he Stomps on the
assault rifle and then no look slides it
away with his foot I just love how many
combinations it takes for John to take
each one down like it not only gives
each Warrior a higher degree of
lethality but it also gives Jon more
accomplishment for each one he's able to
get through John grabs a pair of
nunchucks and uses them to take down two
more suited guards in one fluid motion
he drapes him over his shoulders to free
up his hands to use his pistol he's just
as effective using the chain of the
nunchucks to trip his opponents and then
he Stomps on a guy's crotch just to get
him to sit up right into the angle of
his gun and then blam as the fight goes
on Jon just gets more and more
comfortable relying on the nunchucks as
the Firearms just empty too fast for him
it really just becomes a celebration of
tradition and the old way now the bounty
on Jon goes up from 18 million to 20
million Mr Nobody shoots the cane to
help Jon escape and saves Jon outside he
is waiting for that bounty to get up to
50 million like a guy on an oversold
Delta flight waiting for those to get up
to at least fifteen hundred dollars for
room to give up a seat Kane and shimazu
duel in the garden shimazu dies and Kane
lets Akira Escape in general Tina
sawyama and Donnie Yen completely
crushed it in this movie everyone in
this movie was great Mr Nobody decides
to take the job to kill Jon from Digger
Mall gruesomely pulling his hand off the
dagger and as he shakes his bloody hand
with dagger mole we see that he wears
his watch on the inside of his wrist as
Jon always does something soldiers do so
they can check the time while they're
holding a rifle Jon walks up the
snow-covered steps marked with Latin
phrases including odorant Doom mituant
meaning let them hate so long as they
fear us favorite saying of Roman Emperor
Caligula Karen's grave reads vivamos
moriendo EST meaning to live is to die
and beneath anakum Miss meaning my
friend but to live is to die similar to
what Kane and John Wick Exchange in
their Final Duel those who cling to life
die and those who cling to death live
now there are other Graves around
Karen's Rivera Owens Gilbertson Danny
Rivera worked in the art department for
this movie Christopher Gilbertson worked
on the crew as a set armorer presumably
these characters were passed
conciergeous Winston sends John to
Berlin to get his ticket mended by the
riskaruma John's adoptive sister Katya
this is actress Natalia Tena who you'll
know it's Tonks from Harry Potter and
OSHA from Game of Thrones she says if he
kills kylia Harkin she'll mend his
ticket and in this scene she calls him
jardani or miter that John Wick's full
name is jordani jovanovic but hey can I
level for a second with you about March
the month is gross it's not winter it's
not spring it's just gray and wet it's
really a perfect month for not leaving
the house which is just one of the many
reasons why I use factor to get my meals
shipped to me and yes in other videos
you'll hear me talk about doing the same
thing with hellofresh but factor is now
owned by hellofresh I use both and it
makes my life so much easier Factor not
only lets me skip the trip to the
grocery store but I also get to skip
shopping prepping and cleaning up yeah
Factor meals are fresh never Frozen and
ready in two minutes so all you have to
do is just heat and enjoy Factor has 34
weekly options so I never get tired of
what I'm eating plus if you ever want to
switch things up or just pad out the
snack selection in your pantry Factor
has an assortment of over 36 quick bites
smoothies juices and more satisfying
add-ons each meal is prepared by chefs
and approved by dietitians so you know
you'll feel good about what you're
eating no matter what your diet calls
for Factor has keto calorie smart vegan
vegetarian and Protein Plus meals on the
menu each week this month one of the
things I got was this like sun-dried
tomato chicken with chopped up broccoli
on the side it was so amazing
yeah I said young before I bit into it
because I knew how damn good it would be
that's not cool really good to get some
easy delicious meals of your own just
head to factor75.com or click the link
below and use the code rockstars50 to
get 50 off your first Factor box once
more that's factor75.com and use the
code rockstars50 to get 50 off your
first Factor box John ends up in a
ridiculously rigged game of five card
draw with Killa Kane and Mr Nobody and
Jon picks up his Ace of Spades from his
two Pair of Aces over Eights to slice
killa's neck remember that Ace of Spades
was the card that Kayla initially
flourished in its face similar to the
red circle fight in the first film Jon
has to fight his way through these
oblivious dancing clevers and then it
gets thrown off a balcony but rather
than just being one story he falls onto
a pipe burst and then hits the floor but
this time overall it's a mission
accomplished he eventually kills Killa
and he takes one of his golden teeth as
a trophy it is proof now Winston meets
Duggar mole in the Louvre in front of
the famous painting of LIberty Leading
the People this is commemorating the
July Revolution of 1830 not the 1789
revolution in Digger mole asks if
Winston wants to go the way of rush now
he's referring to the boy in the
painting who is the inspiration of the
character gavrosh in Les Miserables a
character who dies a martyr as Winston
wished she was actually killed a martyr
instead of Left Alive to be branded a
coward or a turncoat at the end of the
scene Winston stops in front of the
larger painting this is the raft of the
Medusa a painting meant to show every
type of emotion humans can have in a
crisis at one point dakormo watches a
Parisian Ballerina by herself in the
theater could it be a tease her Anna to
armis's ballerina spin-off movie in the
John Wick Universe River Chapter 3 The
resange out to Houston's character the
director who set up the idea that
assassins could be trained as dancers in
New York I just think anytime we see a
ballerina John Wick movie we're gonna
have to wonder that so John and Marquis
set the terms for their Jewel Jon gets a
new ballistic suit from the Bowery King
and diagram all tries to slow Jon down
and kill him by up at the bounty to 26
million and this is announced over a
radio DJ we see her mouth shown in close
up this is an homage by director chats
to helski to Walter Hills the Warriors
which has a very similar sequence of a
DJ calling the gangs in New York to stop
the Warriors from reaching Coney Island
and also features the song of nowhere to
run nowhere to hide the song then
switches over to a cover of painted
black as John fights in the street and
drives through the roundabout around the
Arctic Shield I love this sequence
especially the great moment when Jon is
in a shootout with Chidi and he uses a
passing bus as a chance to reload the
Bounty gets up to 40 million and the
fight breaks out into this residential
building where Jon gets a hold of a
dragon's breath shotgun whoa baby and
there is an incredible two minute Warner
following Jon's movement from overhead
this reminds me a lot of the game
Hotline Miami also one of my favorite
scenes Minority Report when those spider
bots were checking everyone's eyes but
even more than the perfectly timed
stunts in the movement of all this I'm
just most impressed with the set design
and the construction each room has a
different floor pattern and specific
Furniture layout to make each room look
distinct and interesting from above John
wrestles with Mr Nobody But when Jon
sees Chidi about to shoot a dog and
remembering Chidi throwing that dog into
a car in the roundabout earlier Jon
remembers how this all started with poor
poor Daisy and he shoots cheaty to save
the dog and Jon has to ascend the
infamous steps of sakakur in Paris I
climb these stairs before they are no
joke remember this movie began with Jon
in the Underworld quoting Dante's
Inferno and now Jon must have to fight
his way back up out of hell and you
totally feel the pain even breaths as he
makes those final steps just for
freaking cheaty to show up and kick him
back down all of the steps first just
halfway down and then again all the way
back down to the ground level oh God but
his friend Kane helps him and as they
make their way back up the stairs Chidi
gets stabbed in the hand with a
pain seal Kane's the one who did it this
time but we know John Wick loves to kill
people pencils and the Mr Nobody has a
dog bites cheating in the balls Mr
Nobody Waits just a bit long to shoot
him and then dog pees him yeah okay and
they make it just in time for sunrise
for their Jewel Kane having to serve as
Dr moles Champion they step out 30 Paces
shot one goes into both their arms 20
Paces Jon gets hit in the shoulder cane
in the abdomen and then 10 Paces out
those who cling to death live those who
cling to life die and Kane shoots John
but you do not see Jon's pistol go off
so when dog Ramon tries to execute him
Jon has one bullet left of the chamber
and Ian mcshane's delivery was so good
as he says you arrogant [__] he
hasn't shut yet now as Jon bleeds on the
steps we flash back to Jon and Helen for
the first film he says her name Helen
and he rolls over now the next scene
Winston and the Barry King Stand over
John and Helen's Graves with John's Pit
Bull from the first movie and John's
grave now reads a loving husband as he
requested earlier but the golden sunrise
over Manhattan contrasting the dark rain
that poured over this graveyard in the
2014 now there's a post credit scene
showing Kane returning to Paris to
reunite with his daughter but Akira
jumps in with a knife so who knows
whether he lives or dies it seems like
they might have shot the scene where it
seemed like Kane died but then they
re-edited it to leave it open-ended
speaking of open-ended endings even
though chats to Hells he has said that
they might take a break from John Wick
films for a while and just focus instead
on the Continental prequel spin-off
series and the ballerina spin-offs and
despite the fact that Reeves has said
they only really made a fourth film to
deal with the reality of Jon's death I
do not think Jon is dead our man has
ended movies bleeding out before and I'm
not just saying this because they want
to make money I just think Keanu Reeves
likes making these stunt driven movies
with his buds but I do like how when the
bower King asks if Jon is in heaven or
in hell and Winston says who knows we do
get a close-up of the dog which just
makes it feel like Jon is still alive to
me but it is pretty cool how we end this
movie in a graveyard after the Marquee
earlier call John quote a ghost looking
for a graveyard another reminder to
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive and he gets support us by grabbing
some merch at nerd riot.shop follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at EA boss fall
into rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]